this one is it's it's terrifying and
funny at the same time the
post-millennial PornHub pulls out of
Virginia over age verification law what
wait wait what
are you hold on there a minute
they blocked users in Virginia from
accessing the site in reaction to the
State's new age verification law
according to 8 News the new Lodge takes
effects July 1st would require porn
websites to verify using the state are
at least 18 before they can access adult
content
so instead of you know verifying age
they were just like well then you look
at any porn they did the same thing in
Utah in early may they they are so
desperate to show children adult images
they boycott the state when they can't
well I don't think that's it I just
because they don't want to deal with any
of the legal ramifications we've been
having to certify all these people
because then now they're liable if they
show kids porn so I just think that's
why they do it because the law is even
right so what you're saying is Pornhub
has no problem operating in the states
if it means children can access their
content well yeah I mean they want kids
to access it but they don't want to have
the risk the Legacy it's too much work
for PornHub to have to make sure kids
aren't using there that's fair yeah I
agree with you I'd say yes it's too much
it's not cost uh beneficial for them in
May when they blocked Utah because Utah
made the same you have to be able to
show your driver's license or verify
they're like this is crazy having to
show your ID every time you come to
Pornhub it's just not going to protect
children like that was their actual
complaint they said that this is a
ridiculous way to handle it so like
strip clubs that don't check IDs yeah
but Tim we're joking about this but the
United Nations came out and saying they
want to get rid of age of consent laws
so it's like they really do want to show
kids adult content and then when we talk
about PornHub like you know they say
it's so crazy for a kid under 18 to look
at porn which I agree with but like a 14
year old can get a mastectomy I mean you
know it's just it's so weird yeah yeah
18 year old you know 17 year old can't
get a tattoo but they can get gender
reassignments they're chanting that
they're coming for our children yes and
then when people are like hey did you
hear what they said they're like no no
they didn't say it they didn't say it
but you know they do say it all the time
we say it every year yeah it's our it's
our chant we always say it was just a
joke no we we say it all the time but
this one time we actually didn't say we
just say it all the time another weird
twisting the PornHub thing is that
Louisiana also has an age verification
lot but PornHub never blocked them and
did comply did they yeah and I don't
know why that is they just said okay
Louisiana it's because they're so
backwards they wouldn't be able to
prosecute it or something I went to LSU
is the wildest place if you guys spend
any time in Louisiana because it was the
last state to change its drinking age
laws from 18 to 21 they were like the LA
the last day to get Federal funding for
the roads so the roads and highways suck
in New Orleans yeah that's see that's
that's Louisiana it's like this thing
it's called lag nappy it's like a little
extra like they have this very nice kind
of party atmosphere but because of that
the city's like run like trash you know
the whole State's just not run very well
it's crazy to me we talked about this uh
this past week there are tons of things
you can't do in public that you can do
online in public which makes no sense
there are tons of things we wouldn't
allow someone to do at a brick and
mortar establishment we allow them to do
online which makes no sense I think it's
because you can't walk into an adult
bookstore you get your ID checked you
can't walk into a section you get your
ID checked online you can no ID check
that's insane to me it should be that
every porn website or adult website
requires registration and verification
before you can use it sorry that's just
that's just the way it works well
there's an interesting discussion going
on about Twitter in that regard too
because you can create a Twitter account
at 13 but they they also allow porno
they should yeah hold on hold on I think
Twitter
Tech so here's the technicality
it's not so much Twitter's business
if you go out into Times Square with a
big photograph of porn you'll get
arrested
so if you post porn on Twitter where
children can see it it's legal it's it
should be the same crime
I don't understand the argument for yes
I understand you can't play videos of
porn out in the public but I should be
able to play it in the public on Twitter
where children can see no no no none of
that none of that what do you think the
remedy for that is police enforcing the
law oh well how would they enforce that
they would see an account post the
illegal content then subpoena the
company and say under this law it's
illegal and a judge orders you to hand
over the data of the individual then
they would go get a warrant like they
would go to the house and investigate
and like any other criminal case like
let me ask you a question a guy wearing
a ski mask is is handing out porn mags
to people in Times Square and holding a
big how do they stop that
shoplifting is rampant in San Francisco
because we're letting it be just because
we never enforce the law doesn't mean we
just don't do it anymore we have to be
like yo we got to stop it we need more
resources for cyber crimes though I was
going to say do you think we need to
expand cyber crime research because
you're saying a shoplifting you send a
police officer in person like do we have
a gap in law enforcement where they are
not trained to uh
it's not it's not it's not that because
many of these people post their their
own videos to the public under their own
names it's that law enforcement and
government can't keep up with technology
yeah so like they don't have a big
enough presence on Twitter to catch them
no it's that if you go to a cop and say
uh if you go to a police officer
PlayStation right now and say there's a
guy who lives a block away from here who
is posting he he was showing
pornographic images in public and
children could see it that cops gonna go
whoa okay let's write this on where was
it it was on Twitter he'll go oh I don't
care about that yeah yeah what's the
difference well and I I told you this
before Tim but they I had a serious
stalker who was stalking me through
Twitter YouTube yeah
I'm funny
uh stalker and the f I ended up getting
involved involved and I had an agent
from the Cyber crimes unit who called me
and he said have you tried calling
Twitter and YouTube and I said with all
due respect sir if you think I could
call Twitter or YouTube you should not
be working in cyber crimes and this was
a federal agent FBI agent you can't take
a big poster of two adults having sex
and put it in your front window for
everyone in the world to walk past and
see you can't do that yeah but Tim if
you want to Legalize It by all means go
to legislature and have them all vote to
make that legal yeah but my buddy
Cassidy Campbell another guy Alex Rosen
they do these Predator posting videos to
him and I'm sure you've seen those where
they'll go in some cities the cops do
get involved but they'll show Cops a
whole cachet of these are texts messages
this guy thinks he's messaging a 13 year
old kid in the cops they have the
evidence they'll say oh we can't touch
it so it's it I think it comes down to
yeah back to blue baby yeah I know it
comes down to you know are they actually
they'll give you a ticket for having a
busted headlight that you didn't know
about they'll they'll they'll you're a
day past your plate registration you'll
get a ticket you'll be speeding you'll
be under the limit but they'll pull you
over and give you a speeding ticket
anyway these stories are rampant
everybody has some ridiculous story I
knew a dude who uh turned right at a
right red light and they mailed him a a
blowing a red light ticket yeah because
he didn't stop long enough no he did oh
they said the the it thought he ran the
light outright yeah they don't care when
it comes to petty crime they'll enforce
it with a hammer when it comes to covert
restrictions they will lock you up hair
salon owner right to jail you own a cafe
in Minnesota and you open up for a
couple days they hunted her down in Iowa
to make sure and this is the sheriff to
make sure she suffered attila's gym you
want to open your gym so people can
exercise because you disagree with the
edict issued by the governor the cops
will show up with smiles on their faces
and arrest you but heaven forbid any one
of these cops when they're standing
outside of a club that is doing a sex
show that they've invited children to
the cops in Texas said sorry we won't do
anything about that I think it's the the
difference of putting up like porn in a
front window facing out onto the street
and putting it on Twitter is that on
Twitter it's parentally supervised like
you're what a kid can't get internet
without that's not true buying a router
and having or buying a phone I kind of
agree with what Ian saying there's a
difference between like posting a
picture and then sending that posted
picture directly to somebody if that
makes sense like I'm not talking about
that I'm saying if you post a tweet of
porn as many people do I view that the
exact same as taking a big sign of the
porn picture and stick it in the ground
outside
a kid in a school library well then it's
the school should be you know an
argument over resources and an argument
for Public Access
no it's not what if it costs 100 bucks
to get into something then it's not
public okay A a kid who doesn't have bus
fare is not the issue if you post it in
public you are granting access to but
like that's the issue just because some
kids can't get on Twitter doesn't mean
it's not public it is public that's the
argument it's not I don't know if it
legally you would consider internet
public it is it is it's literally it's
illegally considered public it is it is
legally
they've already ruled in court if it's
public then how come they a guy can shut
it down
slow down there Ian first there's things
called privately on public spaces where
uh in New York for instance that's what
occupies
and Chase Plaza and Deutsche Bank
privately owned but public and so there
were certain restrictions on what they
couldn't couldn't do and so once it got
to a certain point of the protest they
couldn't shut it down Chase was smart
and shut down their Plaza instantly
before any of that could happen Twitter
is privately owned but it's already been
ruled a public space hence politicians
when they tweet they create public
forums they cannot block people courts
have already stated that now I think
this I'm suing AOC right over this
because she blocked you and it's a
public space she doesn't have a right to
do it it is in public period it's not
it's not up for debate it is the courts
have already said it so the issue is law
enforcement knows that adults are are
publishing images in public that
children can get access to but for some
reason they don't care they won't go
anywhere near it hours our society is in
decay
go back 30 years and watch what happens
if a guy would print out a big poster
with with people having sex on it and
stand in public in in the Town Center
waving it at people he would like bad
things would happen to that guy the
agent arrested data proliferation we
haven't been able to keep up you can
make 100 million copies of something now
but we don't have 100 million copies of
the cop we only have one cop so you need
AI I think we need artificial
intelligence to police no social media
oh no I mean you give me a better option
no I'd love to hear a better one
terrible at distinguishing things right
it's better than no people like zero
people is even worse than they are the
issue is not
that we need a better system for it the
issue is quite simply the culture
police will see it and go meh it's like
how do you find out who did it even
because a lot of the accounts are fake
or so how about this you can't if you
shoot Twitter then you destroy Twitter
how about this in all instances where an
individual under their given name and
photograph publish it
then the investigation is quite minimal
you then
go knock on their door and say Mr Smith
did you publish this image to your
Twitter account you did place your hands
behind your back you're under arrest for
posting lewd images in public
did you know that in many states if you
have a gun
and that gun is in a position where a
child could get access to it that is a
felony yeah so like if it's in your room
locked in the closet oh hold on there a
minute it's got to be in a safe
they have these child protection laws
what about West Virginia we already
talked about it open lewdness is illegal
what about retweeting porn should that
those people also be arrested that's an
interesting question that we'll be up
for it is kind of a gray area well
that's a court that requires precedent
and that's a normal process in the
United States law a police officer will
say you published this image to your you
know 10 000 followers they'll say no I
retweeted something that was already
public then the argument becomes a guy
was handing out pictures of porn in
public handed you one and you held it up
in the air for everyone so you think you
are now in trouble with like um when
when data is leaked like government
leaks and things and then people retweet
the data like are they committing the
same felony that the person that's a
whistleblower because they're basically
holding up the elite no because it's not
illegal to share it it's illegal to
steal it so when it comes to like the
Pentagon papers the question is was it
illegally obtained well there's
whistlebar protections the news media
committed no crime by publishing that
information
Tim I want to make a point about the
culture though and it's like this is a
more simple analogy not just the fact
that everybody's trying to basically
give kids gender reassignment surgery
and make everybody get an abortion but
just look at the the change of our
architecture from the 60s and 70s
brutalism I mean hey it's this weird
post-modern era of just crap like even
the newest baseball stadium in Texas we
had the ballpark in Arlington built in
like 99 it's just beautiful you know
grandiose epic and a ballpark the newest
one they built I forget it's called
Globe Life or forget what it's even
called and it looks like a Costco I'm
just saying in the past 20 years where
we've gone down when it comes to
architecture just imagine brutalism yeah
everything's everything's a white box
and that's crap that's that's terrible
no there's no art there's we we but you
know what it is I was talking to Sheamus
about it he was saying that before the
internet and print this was the art
medium to see the great works was the
buildings we would produce then as we
move into newspaper and radio art and
creativity moved into those spaces
building started becoming less and less
relevant in the discussion I think
that's part of it I think it's also
there's a lot of planned obsolescence
that goes into that yeah I feel like
it's like to make everyone feel like
there's no uh Regional significance
right like if you're in New York City
you can tell by the buildings and
they're supposed to be different than
the buildings that are in San Francisco
which are supposed to be different than
the buildings that you might find in
like a major city in Montana whereas now
you get major corporations that put up
the same blank building everywhere so
there's no sense of identity and
therefore you can't cultivate any sort
of uh Regional pride and it's like when
people build new houses there's always
problems but houses built in like the
70s and 60s it just last the test of
time it seems like so there's something
there's like a degradation of the
Carpenters like like look at this the
the Gargoyles and stuff outside of these
buildings in New York City they can't
even repair them we don't even have the
same people the stone masons that can
even do that Plastering but it seems to
be like the big thing there are very few
true Plastering Crews left on the issue
of porn let me give you guys a very
simple scenario if if you want to post
it to your Twitter account your account
has to be age verify verification locked
that's it so you will make a post and if
you publish it to people now you're in
trouble if like to if open to the public
for children if you want to do adult
content to make it safe and legal you
put a age restriction filter on it and
then if a kid comes across it they can't
access it and the only people who can
are those who verify their accounts on
Twitter I'll give you a real world
example you walk into a 7-Eleven back
when I was a kid and there were some
magazines but those magazines were in
black plastic you could not see the
magazine you could see the top that it
would say the name Hustler or Playboy
but you'd like oh man you can see it and
kids weren't able to buy it they can't
sell you that so you couldn't actually
open it up it was wrapped you couldn't
see you could only see it was a product
so it was in public but not displaying
anything for kids to see what about if
someone's sitting on a park bench with a
Playboy reading it and there's a kid
like 500 100 feet away walking by yeah
typically then a cop will be like hey
buddy come on there are kids around here
put that away but if the kid walks up
behind the guy and looks at the magazine
over his shoulder then typically someone
will say hey buddy put that thing away
if a kid would be the one that makes a
mistake in that now you're talking about
simple like a Judicial discretion I
guess the question is is it illegal to
have a Playboy open in a public park
that the question of legality is the
interpretation of the judge he a cop
could say disorderly conduct for
anything you do you can fart in public
and a cop can be like that's disorderly
you're under arrest and tell to a judge
the judge will then determine whether or
not you actually violated that statute
I know I got a felony for farting in
public it was gross it's really bad a
lot of poop in that part oh one of those
yeah it was really bad like a horizontal
thing I went to jail for a long time I
just got a burst no but uh I don't know
just got out when it comes to the porn
stuff on the internet I I think that's
kind of the the most cancerous thing of
the reason why kids are so sexualized
and I think that's why we have a lot of
this I'm depressed well not just a
depression but the sexual confusion
because you look at like a trans person
you might be attracted to the boobs I
think you see a penis because they go to
a drag queen story time at a young age
so I'm just saying we're over
sexualizing our children and that's
having just it's having an effect that
we can't you know quantify or whatever
we can't figure out what the hell that's
going to equal because we don't have any
past Generations that were exposed we
kind of do it's it's creating sexual
dysfunction we're saying that um uh
erectile dysfunction is skyrocketing in
our young men and uh testosterone's way
down that could be Plastics I think
that's probably our diet and stuff like
that but kids kids human beings were
never meant to be exposed to this level
of information period that okay but I
understand information access is just a
thing that we're going to learn to adapt
with
children being able to get instant
access to porn on Twitter that's a
problem that was an oversight of the
2000s 2000 that people didn't realize
when the internet arrived that they
should be protecting kids brands from it
well Ted Bundy said they should Ted
Bundy said if you don't want your kids
to end up like me keep them away from
porn I think interesting the way Twitter
should work is the moment your account
posts porn available to the public you
get an instant age verification that's
what I'm talking about AI that you'd use
AI for something like that but it could
fail but I think you could use AI to do
it because if a person's like oops I
forgot you don't want to throw them in
prison for that necessarily I forgot
what I forgot to post 18 age
verification on that on mine and you're
like whoops I accidentally threw a
Playboy in front of a bunch of kids like
what like that's when you bring up like
wanting to read a pornographic magazine
in a park for me it's like but why do
you want it if you're going to park
where presumably our children whoever
like yeah
but but the point I'm learning earlier
is there there is there is a reasonable
this to enforcing the law that is upon
the discretion of the officer it is
unreasonable in my opinion that officers
do not arrest the people who are
engaging in these crimes completely
unreasonable it would be unreasonable it
is unreasonable in my opinion so
if you get pulled over
and it's an honest mistake and you
weren't speeding that much the
reasonable thing to do is a warning and
cops do that a lot that's police
discretion and many officers do a good
job I have had some negative encounters
with police officers if most people have
where one time I was not speeding I got
a ticket cop told me to basically screw
myself and that got my license suspended
that bothers me it bothers me that that
kind of thing can exist where a cop can
screw your life up through no fault of
your own but we can't get him to arrest
people who are exposing children to
adult sex shows like that's my like I
recognize pencils of erasers bad cops
exist and these things happens I'm not
um it's under the water under the bridge
I'm like okay you know these are things
that are part of the system but why then
do we struggle to stop this because they
are focused primarily on immediate
Public Safety so like driving is a big
part of it they don't want a car to hit
a human in the human time like the kids
getting sexualized doesn't have like an
immediate
thing you notice like there's no
immediate change in their physical
health when they when it happens so the
cop doesn't really have like a thing to
stop right away I mean when you think
about it and you realize what's
happening then you can start to make the
argument that we need to do some
preventative measures but they're more
interested in just like stopping
violence I just think our culture is
shattered I think that it's the internet
has ripped it to shreds there's no more
unified sense of morality and now among
cops for the most part they're just like
I want to keep my head down and stay out
of it
so in Texas famously you had a drag show
with kids and they were sexualized
things going on in there and the cops
were like I ain't doing anything about
this and it's just like yo we could just
Google the law and show you it's illegal
and the cop's like don't look at me I'm
not getting involved thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time